Profª. Tamar Gendler:
Bem-vindos ao curso de Filosofia
e a Ciência da Natureza Humana.
É bom ver tanta gente aqui hoje.
Espero ver ainda mais
pessoas na quinta-feira.
O meu objetivo de hoje é
tentar oferecer a vocês
uma noção de como será este curso,
para que vocês possam
tomar uma decisão
bem fundamentada sobre se realmente
querem se inscrever nele.
Com essa intenção em mente,
há 3 coisas que eu quero
fazer na aula de hoje.
Na 1ª parte, eu vou apresentar
uma ampla visão geral de
como é o curso
e comentar  os meus
objetivos neste curso.
Na maior parte da aula, o que eu
vou fazer é percorrer
3 exemplos dos tópicos
que abordaremos neste semestre,
para vocês terem uma noção
do tipo de material
que estaremos examinando.
E, na parte final, eu vou falar
sobre algumas coisas
diferenciais deste curso
e algumas coisas relacionadas
às suas exigências.
Portanto, o curso tem este
título entremeado estranho.
É chamado de Filosofia e a
Ciência da Natureza Humana
e está listado tanto na filosofia
quanto na ciência cognitiva,
e possui a maioria dos créditos
relacionados à Psicologia.
Então, que tipo de curso é este?
De certa forma, é um curso como
o de Estudos Dirigidos
de Filosofia ou Filosofia 125-126.
Ou seja, vamos ler obras de
Platão, Aristóteles, Epicteto,
Boécio, Hobbes, Hume e Mill...
todos os grandes filósofos da
tradição filosófica ocidental.
Vamos lê-los com finalidade histórica,
numa tentativa de chegar a
alguns tipos de perguntas
que se poderia chegar num curso
tradicional de filosofia.
Além disso, vocês
receberão parte do material
que receberiam num curso de ética.
Então, um dos temas que
trataremos em Filosofia
e a Ciência da Natureza Humana
são as 3 principais teorias éticas
da tradição filosófica ocidental.
Vamos falar sobre o
utilitarismo, a deontologia,
a ética das virtudes
e sobre como eles se
relacionam entre si.
Vocês também receberão
materiais que receberiam
se estivessem no curso de
introdução à filosofia política.
Vamos conferir brevemente o
trabalho de Thomas Hobbes
sobre a legitimidade do Estado
e depois ler e refletir sobre o debate
entre John Rawls e Robert
Nozick sobre quanto peso
deve ser dado aos valores relativos
da igualdade e da liberdade.
Portanto, nesse sentido, este
é, em alguns aspectos,
um curso padrão de filosofia da
tradição moral e política.
Não é um curso de metafísica;
não é um curso de epistemologia;
não é um curso onde vamos
falar sobre questões
como o livre-arbítrio ou o
problema mente-corpo,
tudo o que legitimamente
poderia englobar
o tema de filosofia da natureza humana.
Mas a peculiaridade deste curso é
que, além das contribuições
que são feitas pelo lado
filosófico da equação,
também vamos beber na fonte de
várias outras disciplinas.
Assim, um dos principais
temas do curso será
pensar sobre como as
questões levantadas
pelos filósofos tradicionais
que eu mencionei antes
são captadas na tradição da
ciência cognitiva contemporânea.
Em particular, como elas são
captadas por, a meu ver,
uma das principais vertentes
da ciência cognitiva contemporânea,
a vertente que analisa a
relação entre os seres humanos
como criaturas racionais,
capazes de um certo tipo
de compreensão calculada
e reflexiva de si
e do seu lugar no mundo;
e, por outro lado,
os seres humanos como animais
evoluídos sujeitos
a forças que estão além do
controle racional.
A partir do reconhecimento de
que os seres humanos
podem ser afetados de várias formas,
vamos analisar uma série de
textos da psicologia.
Vamos ler um pouco de Freud;
debater sobre a terapia
cognitivo-comportamental;
falar sobre o transtorno de
estresse pós-traumático;
discutir sobre a felicidade,
utilizando um maravilhoso livro
escrito por um ex-aluno de
Yale: Jonathan Haidt.
Vamos ver algumas obras
sobre autorregulação,
amor e amizade, e também
conferir trabalhos empíricos
sobre temas como o raciocínio
moral e a punição
e obras da psicologia social
sobre atitudes e situações.
Ou seja, uma grande parte do
material que abordaremos
neste curso virá da psicologia.
Mas alguma coisa também virá
da ciência política.
Durante a discussão sobre a
legitimidade do Estado,
vamos ser apresentados à noção
do dilema dos prisioneiros.
Vamos falar sobre a
tragédia dos comuns e,
na seção de encerramento do curso,
vamos comentar sobre o
papel da retórica
e da argumentação na
persuasão política.
Também vamos beber na fonte do campo
da economia comportamental.
Uma das tarefas requisitadas
é ouvir o discurso
de Daniel Kahneman no prêmio Nobel,
aceitando o prêmio em seu nome
e do seu colaborador,
Amos Tversky, pelo
trabalho extraordinário
ao fundar a economia comportamental.
Mas vamos conferir ainda alguns
trabalhos adicionais
sobre duplo processamento
e alguns trechos
do delicioso livro de Dan
Ariely, uma obra pública
sobre economia comportamental.
E, finalmente, vamos sugar um
pouco da literatura.
Vamos ler um pequeno trecho da Ilíada;
vamos ler um conto de Ursula Le Guin;
e da 2ª à última aula do curso,
veremos o que Platão tem
a dizer sobre o papel da literatura e
da representação artística
no que toca a autocompreensão humana.
O que eu vou tentar fazer no curso
é reunir esses 8 campos
para oferecer uma
história coerente sobre
que tipos de coisas são
os seres humanos
e como podemos aprender sobre o
que são os seres humanos
a partir dessas várias perspectivas.
Em forma de slogan, a estrutura
do curso é "cara morto
na terça, ciência
cognitiva na quinta".
Apesar de nem todos os
filósofos lidos estarem mortos.
E nem todos serem caras.
E nem todos os outros campos
serem ciência cognitiva.
E, de fato, a maioria das
coisas será tratada junta
na terça e na quinta.
E haverá seções. Mas, acima
de tudo, eis o slogan.
Então essa é uma visão
geral das disciplinas
que contribuem para o curso.
Comento um pouco sobre os
temas específicos
que espero abordar no
decorrer do semestre.
Portanto, o 1º tópico
abrangente... eu organizei
o conteúdo programático
sob esses 3 tópicos,
mas, de alguma forma,
cada um deles vai seguir
reaparecendo ao longo do semestre.
O 1º tópico é o tema da
felicidade e prosperidade.
O que a antiga tradição
filosófica ocidental diz
sobre o que é preciso para os
seres humanos prosperarem
num sentido significativo e como isso
está conectado ao trabalho
que tem sido realizado mais
recentemente em várias tradições
literárias e científicas
sobre o que os permite
prosperarem?
O que tem a natureza humana que é
capaz de nos dar alguma
pista sobre o que poderia ser a
felicidade autêntica?
Esse é o 1º conjunto de
questões que será abordado.
Acontece que a resposta dos
filósofos antigos a essa pergunta é
que os seres humanos
prosperam quando a sua alma
está bem-ordenada, para usar
uma metáfora antiga.
Quando as partes da alma que
costumam puxar para diferentes
direções estão num certo
tipo de harmonia;
e a imagem antiga é que,
quando isso ocorre,
os humanos se comportam de
uma maneira moral.
E assim, a 2ª parte do curso
vai olhar para ambos:
o que se sente por dentro ao se
comportar de maneiras
que são convencionalmente
consideradas morais e,
desde um nível mais elevado,
o que queremos dizer
quando dizemos que um ato
é moral ou imoral.
Então, como eu mencionei,
vamos ver os 3 principais
conceitos filosóficos
ocidentais sobre moralidade
e também algumas questões
interessantes relacionadas.
Tal como: por que a punição é
justificada quando ocorre?
E: a justificativa para a punição
é psicológica ou ética?
Na unidade final do curso,
vamos avançar para além
do indivíduo na sociedade como um todo,
fazer algumas perguntas sobre
o que é que legitima as
estruturas políticas e como
as instituições estatais ou
cívicas devem ser organizadas
a fim de permitir a
prosperidade dos seres
humanos.
Então esses são os 3 principais
temas que abordaremos,
e como você pode ver no conteúdo
programático que eu entreguei,
há exemplos marcados de alguns
desses tópicos específicos
que estamos abordando na 1ª página
e um conjunto muito mais
detalhado de questões
nas páginas 3 e 4.
Mas além de tratar sobre o
conteúdo dessas perguntas,
este curso também vai
incentivar vocês a pensar
sobre a metodologia de cada
uma das disciplinas
que tocaremos. Por isso, é meu
objetivo apresentá-los
a uma série de discussões
filosóficas tradicionais
do ser humano, mas meu objetivo
também é fazer vocês refletirem
sobre o que essas discussões
filosóficas têm em comum
e porque é que pensar sobre as coisas
do modo que a filosofia pensa
pode ser valioso para
responder às perguntas
que nos preocupam.
E vamos fazer algo muito similar no
que diz respeito às outras disciplinas.
Vamos olhar para a literatura a
partir da psicologia,
economia comportamental, ciência
política e literatura
e vamos perguntar: o que tem
esta abordagem distinta,
na hora de responder a essas questões,
que nos fornece uma visão
complementar sobre as questões
levantadas pelos filósofos?
E, finalmente, eu vou pedir que vocês
pensem não só no contexto
desta aula, mas no contexto das outras
aulas que vocês participam,
sobre como o material exposto
lança uma luz através das
múltiplas perspectivas disciplinares
para o conjunto de questões
que nos inquieta.
Então esse é o segmento de
abertura da aula expositiva.
A seção que eu intitulei
"visão geral e tópicos do curso".
E o que eu quero fazer agora é
dar a vocês 3 exemplos
dos tipos de temas que
abordaremos neste semestre.
Assim, o 1º exemplo que eu
vou dar foi retirado
das leituras que faremos
para quinta-feira.
E é uma história que integra A
República de Platão, chamada
o anel de Giges.
Nós vamos ir um pouco mais
a fundo na quinta
sobre onde esta história se encaixa
no contexto do livro no qual
ela é contada, mas tudo o que vocês
precisam saber, por agora,
é que o personagem se chama Glauco,
trata-se de um dos irmãos de Platão,
autor do diálogo. E Glauco conversa com
o grande filósofo grego
antigo Sócrates,
tentando convencê-lo de que quando
as pessoas agem moralmente
a única razão pela qual elas fazem
isso é porque não podem escapar.
Então, mesmo que vocês
venham só hoje,
é uma chance de escutar um
pouco de Platão.
Eu vou ler em voz alta estes
números à direita.
Explico na próxima aula;
eles são chamados de
paginação Stephanus.
Eles permitem que você
encontre a mesma passagem
em qualquer tradução.
E a que eu vou ler está nas páginas
Stephanus 359-360. Portanto:
"Giges era um pastor
a serviço do governante da Lídia.
Por causa de uma grande
tempestade e de um terremoto,
o solo se rachou e criou
uma fenda no local
onde ele cuidava das suas ovelhas.
Vendo isso, ele se encheu de
admiração e desceu pela abertura.
E lá ele viu um cavalo de bronze oco.
Havia portinholas nele e,
espreitando por uma delas,
viu um cadáver vestindo nada mais
que um anel de ouro no dedo.
Giges o pegou e saiu da fenda."
"Ele usava o anel na
reunião mensal habitual
que relatava o estado dos
rebanhos ao rei.
Sentado entre os seus iguais,
ele girou o anel por acaso, de tal modo
que a pedra ficou do lado de
dentro da sua mão.
Imediatamente depois disso, ele
se tornou invisível,
e os outros pastores falavam dele
como se ele tivesse ido embora.
Atônito com o efeito, e
tateando o anel,
ele o virou outra vez para
fora e ficou visível.
Ele repetiu a experiência para testar
se o anel realmente tinha
esse poder, e tinha.
Se Giges virava a pedra para o
interior, se tornava invisível;
para o exterior, estava
visível de novo."
"Quando se deu conta disso, ele
conseguiu se incluir
entre os mensageiros enviados ao rei.
E quando chegou ao palácio,
seduziu a esposa do rei e,
com a ajuda dela, atacou e matou o
rei, assumindo o trono".
Então essa é a história
do anel de Giges.
Mas por que Glauco conta essa história?
Glauco conta a história com a
expectativa de que,
ao ouvir isso, você pense
que agiria como Giges
se tivesse a chance de escapar do crime
sem ser apanhado.
A conclusão de Glauco é que aqueles
que praticam a justiça, que
agem em conformidade
com o código moral da sociedade,
o fazem porque não têm o poder
de praticar a injustiça.
Elem agem dessa forma pois temem a
punição da sociedade.
Elem não agem dessa forma
porque, de algum modo,
isso é valioso para eles.
E a leitura que vamos fazer
para a aula desta quinta
inclui o texto que circunda a
história que eu acabei de contar...
Ou seja, a configuração na qual
Glauco levanta o desafio,
que supõe ser um exemplo...
além da conversa
entre Glauco e Sócrates, que
segue a proposta do desafio
ao longo dessa história. Além disso,
vamos ler alguns trabalhos da
psicologia empírica
sobre o que as pessoas
fazem quando creem
que não estão sendo observadas.
Vamos fazer a pergunta se, na realidade,
as pessoas se comportariam
ou se, na realidade,
as pessoas deveriam se
comportar como Giges.
Esse é o 1º exemplo do tipo de tema
que abordaremos no curso.
O 2º conjunto de temas do curso
vai emergir de um exemplo
filosófico particular
que se tornou bastante popular
nas discussões
contemporâneas da
moralidade,
mas que na verdade pode ser
rastreado, há cerca de 40 anos,
em alguns escritos de Philippa Foot e
da filósofa Judith Thomson.
E o caso, que eu suspeito
que alguns de vocês
já estejam familiarizados,
envolve um trem em direção
a 5 pessoas e que,
se não for desviado dos trilhos,
se chocará contra o grupo.
Agora, a pergunta que os
filósofos gostam de colocar
é a seguinte:
Vamos supor que haja uma alavanca,
que você possa usá-la
para desviar o trem,
de modo que em vez de atingir 5 pessoas,
atinja 1.
Quando tivermos os clickers
[dispositivos eletrônicos de
votação],
seremos capazes de fazer
isto cientificamente.
Por enquanto, eu quero que
vocês levantem as mãos.
Quantos de vocês acham que é
moralmente permitido
ou moralmente obrigatório, ou seja,
permitido ou obrigatório,
não proibido, desviar o trem de
tal forma que ele atinja
1 pessoa em vez de 5?
Quantos acham que é
permitido ou obrigatório
mudar o trajeto causando a morte
de 1 pessoa em vez de 5?
[pausa]
OK. E quantos de vocês acham que
é moralmente proibido
desviar o trem para que ele mate
1 pessoa em vez de 5?
Quantos de vocês acreditam que isso
seja moralmente proibido?
[pausa]
OK. Como eu disse, não
temos os clickers,
mas uma grande maioria da turma
acredita que é permitido
ou obrigatório desviar o trem.
Agora vamos imaginar uma
situação um pouco diferente.
Em vez da pessoa estar nos trilhos,
existe uma ponte sobre os
trilhos do trem.
E em cima da ponte está um senhor
de grande perímetro,
de tal forma que, se você desalojá-lo
usando a mesma alavanca
do caso anterior,
ele seria suficientemente
pesado para impedir
que o trem se chocasse contra os 5.
Quantos de vocês acham que é
moralmente obrigatório
ou moralmente permitido empurrar
o homem gordo da ponte
para evitar que o trem atinja os 5?
[pausa]
E quantos acham que isso é
moralmente proibido?
Mãos para cima de novo.
[pausa]
Muito bem.
Nós temos uma distribuição muito,
muito diferente desta vez.
Agora vamos supor que
estamos no hospital
e os 5 que estavam nos trilhos,
e que foram salvos do trem,
estão terrivelmente feridos,
sendo que 1 precisa de um
coração, 1 precisa de um pulmão,
1 de uma perna, 1 de um braço
e outro de um olho.
E entra um homem saudável
com, exatamente,
os órgãos necessários
para salvar os 5.
Quantos de vocês acham que é
moralmente obrigatório ou moralmente
permitido cortar 1 para salvar os 5?
[pausa]
Eu não quero estar com vocês numa
sala de espera de hospital.
Isso foram 3 mãos.
Quantos de vocês acham que é
moralmente proibido?
[pausa]
Muito bem.
Vamos supor que um urso esteja
vindo na sua direção.
Você está numa fila de pessoas e um
urso vem na sua direção.
Quantos de vocês acham que é
moralmente permitido sair
do caminho do urso se ele está
vindo na sua direção?
[pausa]
OK. Agora, quando isso acontece, o
urso vai devorar o rapaz
que está bem atrás de você.
OK. Caso número dois:
Vamos supor que um urso esteja
vindo na sua direção.
Quantos de vocês acham que é
moralmente permitido
pegar o rapaz que está atrás de você
e colocá-lo na sua frente para
se proteger do urso?
[pausa]
Um panorama muito diferente desta vez.
OK. O que está acontecendo aqui?
No caso original em que
redirecionamos o trem,
1 pessoa vai morrer se virarmos o trem
e outras 5 vão viver.
No caso do empurrão do homem
gordo, se o empurrarmos,
1 pessoa vai morrer e
outras 5 vão viver.
No caso do paciente, o levamos para
o hospital e o fatiamos.
1 pessoa vai morrer e
outras 5 vão viver.
No caso do urso, quando você se esquiva
e ele abocanha o cara atrás de
você, o cara morre e você vive.
No caso do urso em que você pega
o rapaz atrás de você
e coloca na sua frente,
usando-o como escudo,
ele morre e você vive.
Então, o 2º conjunto de temas
que eu quero apresentar
trata do seguinte:
O que explica as diferenças de
nossas reações a esses casos?
Existe, de modo genuíno, uma
diferença moralmente relevante
entre desviar o trem, para que
ele mate 1 em vez de 5,
e empurrar o homem gordo, para que
o trem mate 1 em vez de 5?
Ou a diferença da nossa reação a esses 2
casos é meramente psicológica?
Existe realmente uma diferença
moral entre a esquiva,
de modo que um dano que se dirigia a
você acerte outra pessoa,
e a blindagem, de modo que um dano
que vem na sua direção
recaia sobre outra pessoa?
O que explica as diferenças de
nossas reações a esses casos?
Quais são as implicações morais
e quais são as
implicações
psicológicas?
Esse é o 2º conjunto de exemplos
que eu quero apresentar,
um tema que será abordado.
3ª série de exemplos.
Imagino que alguns de vocês
estejam familiarizados
com a seguinte situação:
Você vai à biblioteca com a
intenção sincera
de ler o Platão atribuído
para a próxima aula
e, em vez disso, se vê
respondendo e-mails.
Ou você definiu uma dieta
alimentar em que comerá muita
quantidade de frutas e legumes
e, em vez disso, está
tentado por um bolo.
Ou você se compromete a guardar
dinheiro para alguma meta a
longo prazo e, em vez disso, se sente
atraído pela possibilidade
de uma viagem à Jamaica
com os seus amigos
ou de um iPod touch ou um novo
acessório de PlayStation
que você usa como
distração da leitura.
O que é isso nos seres humanos que
os fazem traçar esses tipos
de planos e depois não agirem em
conformidade com eles?
E o que é que podemos fazer para
nos ater aos compromissos
feitos em momentos de reflexão?
A leitura atribuída para hoje
é um capítulo muito curto do
popular livro de Dan Ariely.
É um capítulo sobre a
procrastinação.
E nele, Dan descreve uma série de
estratégias que podemos usar
para nos ajudar com os
compromissos a longo prazo.
Por exemplo, uma das coisas
que as pessoas fazem
se querem ler é ir à biblioteca
e se cercar por outras
pessoas que estão lendo.
Se você está num ambiente
social onde outras pessoas
estão em conformidade com um
padrão que você tenha definido,
talvez você se encontre em
conformidade com o padrão
e não fazendo algo que
acabará se arrependendo.
Se você se sente tentado por um
alimento proibido por você mesmo,
pode ser útil limitar o
seu acesso a ele.
No capítulo que lemos, Dan
Ariely descreve um exemplo
que ele chamou de solução do cartão
de crédito congelado, em que,
se você tem uma tendência a
comprar por impulso na internet,
você pega o seu cartão de
crédito, coloca num copo d'água
e dentro do congelador.
E então, se quiser comprar algo,
você tira o cartão do congelador
e se quando a água tiver derretido
você ainda quiser comprar,
então vá em frente.
Ou seja, restringir o nosso acesso
imediato aos itens tentadores
é uma maneira de contornar o problema.
Uma 3ª maneira de contornar
esses tipos de problemas
é automatizar o comportamento que
você deseja estimular.
Portanto, se eu criar um sistema
no meu cartão de crédito
onde cada vez que eu gaste
US$ 10, outros US$ 10
vão para a minha conta poupança,
em vez de gastar dinheiro com o
que estou comprando,
vou economizar dinheiro para o
que estou comprometido.
A questão filosófica e
psicológica levantada
nesta parte do curso é a seguinte:
Que tipo de seres são capazes
de planejar reflexivamente
e, ao mesmo tempo,
não agir com base no plano?
Parece ser exatamente o tipo de pessoas
que obtivemos informações nos
nossos 2 exemplos anteriores.
São as que possuem uma
autorreflexividade,
capazes da razão e do compromisso,
além de aspectos em si mesmas que
respondem irrefletidamente às
características do entorno.
Assim sendo, que tipo de estratégias
estão disponíveis para ajudar
essas pessoas a manterem os seus
planos reflexivamente endossados?
A resposta básica é que existem
2 tipos de estratégias.
Um tipo de estratégia envolve o
aumento da utilidade relativa
do compromisso reflexivo, isto é,
tornando-o mais saliente
para você em qualquer tipo de caminho.
Que a leitura, o brócolis e os
cofrinhos são valiosos.
E o outro tipo de estratégia
envolve a redução
de apelo da estratégia de
tentação temporária:
reduzir o acesso ao e-mail,
reduzir o acesso ao alimento,
tornar mais difícil fazer a viagem.
Então, uma das coisas abordadas
no contexto do curso,
em pequenas e em grandes dimensões,
é este ponto fulcral da
procrastinação como uma forma de
compreender
um vasto número de estruturas
sociais: leis, códigos morais,
punições, estratégias de
autorregulação.
Todos são aspectos da
sociedade que jogam
com as 2 estratégias
fundamentais descritas.
Eles jogam com: como
fazemos certas coisas
reflexivamente endossadas
serem mais valiosas
ou como fazemos certas coisas
que desejamos não seguir
serem menos aceitáveis.
Assim, esse é o 3º exemplo
do tipo de tópico
tratado neste semestre.
Então, o que eu quero fazer
nestes minutos finais é falar
um pouco sobre algumas
características distintivas do
curso.
A 1ª coisa, que alguns de
vocês devem ter notado,
é que na parte de trás da sala
está um cinegrafista.
O motivo dele estar aqui
é porque a aula
está sendo gravada para o site
da Open Yale Courses.
Isso significa que existe a
possibilidade de
que a sua voz seja
capturada pelo áudio.
E se isso ocorrer, vamos precisar da
sua permissão para reproduzi-la
na versão iTunes University desta aula.
Mas também é uma chance de
conseguir fama e fortuna, pessoal.
Acredito que por ser um curso
da Open Yale Courses
tudo será o mais discreto possível,
mas se alguém tem alguma dúvida,
sinta-se à vontade para
entrar em contato.
A 2ª coisa que distingue este curso, e
que eu acho a mais importante,
é que ele é, em alguns
aspectos, sobre si mesmo.
Os recursos pedagógicos do
curso são projetados
com a ideia crucial de fundamentar
todas as leituras na mente.
Eu parto do princípio de que
todos vocês estão comprometidos com
a leitura e a aprendizagem,
e engajados com o material.
E o meu objetivo é tornar
isso o mais fácil,
emocionante e interessante possível.
Portanto, como vocês já perceberam
no conteúdo programático,
se já tiveram uma oportunidade
de dar uma olhada nele,
existem tarefas quase
semanais nesta aula.
Mas elas são concebidas para estimular
o envolvimento entre
vocês e o material.
Por exemplo, a 1ª tarefa,
que está descrita no
verso da folha azul,
pergunta se você quer se
comprometer, de forma voluntária,
a não ter acesso à
internet durante esta aula
e, em seguida, pede para você
explicar a sua decisão,
fazendo referência ao texto
sobre procrastinação
que lemos para esta semana.
O meu objetivo durante o semestre
será passar exercícios
que os impliquem dessa maneira.
Um dos exercícios envolve
escrever uma resenha de um conto
a partir da perspectiva de um
dos 2 filósofos lidos.
Uma das tarefas envolve a
concepção de uma semana
de uma versão futura deste curso.
Então, embora exista 10
tarefas semanais, espero
que o envolvimento com elas os
mantenha conectados ao curso.
Na verdade, muitas leituras do
conteúdo programático
foram sugestões feitas pelos
alunos que participaram
da versão seminário deste
curso nos anos anteriores.
Além disso, como vocês viram
nos dilemas do Trolley,
eu vou pedir, no contexto da aula,
para vocês pensarem sobre
casos e exemplos.
E para isso consideramos que
o uso dos clickers
é extremamente útil para
manter os alunos engajados.
Portanto, vocês notarão que a 2ª
parte da tarefa da semana
que vem pedirá que vocês, caso estejam
no curso para obter crédito,
peguem um clicker na biblioteca Bass
e registrem o número dele
no site do curso.
Assim que o curso começar a engrenar,
a partir da metade da segunda semana,
vamos passar a usar os clickers.
Por último, uma das coisas que
distingue este curso é que
no ano passado eu realmente fui uma
estudante em tempo integral,
como relata o Yale Daily News.
Eu tinha uma bolsa da Fundação
Mellon que me permitiu
assistir às aulas e eu passei a
maior parte do ano sentada
na última fileira de salas como esta,
assistindo a aulas como esta.
Foi assim que eu tive a ideia sobre
desligar a internet. Ahã.
Mas isso também me ajudou a perceber
que o ritmo do semestre é
algo complicado.
Então, como vocês podem
ver, a 2ª frase
do artigo do Yale Daily News diz:
"As suas notas ultimamente têm decaído
um pouco – de um 'excelente'
nas duas primeiras tarefas
a um 'positivo'
ao concluir as duas mais recentes".
Eu prometo que não vou publicar as
notas de vocês no Yale Daily News.
Mas prometo que eu sou, como
resultado dessa experiência,
profundamente ciente de que as
tarefas estruturantes pedidas
com antecedência são
cruciais para permitirem
o sucesso dos alunos no curso.
Eu tentei ser a mais clara possível
no conteúdo programático.
E se vocês forem nas
páginas 4 e 5, vão ver
que existem 5 tipos de
requisitos para o curso.
O 1º, e talvez mais importante,
é o conjunto de leituras
atribuído a vocês.
E essas leituras vêm em 2 formatos.
Cerca de metade delas vêm de 6 livros
que eu encomendei para vocês
na Labyrinth Books.
Todos os livros são edições com
desconto para estudantes.
Todos eles são fáceis de encontrar.
E juntos, mesmo se forem comprados
novos pelo preço normal,
somam US$ 80.
Portanto, algumas das tarefas nascem
tanto das 3 obras clássicas
que leremos, de Platão,
Aristóteles e Epicteto,
quanto das 2 obras contemporâneas:
Happiness Hypothesis, de Jonathan Haidt,
e um livro de Jonathan Shea
chamado Achilles in Vietnam.
E, finalmente, eu pedi para
vocês comprarem
um pequeno dicionário de
filosofia, de US$ 15,
que será muito útil na
pesquisa de termos e conceitos
com os quais vocês podem não
estar familiarizados.
Eu entendo, porém, que alguns de
vocês ainda não terão decidido
se participarão deste curso
antes da quinta-feira.
E por isso mesmo metade da leitura
de quinta vem deste livro;
eu coloquei as páginas relevantes no
nosso servidor Classes*v2.
Vocês podem fazer a leitura
para quinta mesmo
se ainda não tiverem comprado o livro.
Portanto, cerca de metade das
leituras vem desses livros.
Cerca de metade das leituras vem de
artigos e todas essas leituras
estão disponíveis no servidor
*v2 para a próxima aula.
Mas além de escolher os
livros que eu acho
que são sensatos e interessantes,
também fiz um esforço para
fornecer uns guias de leitura,
com a intenção de orientação.
Se vocês olharem as 3 primeiras
páginas da folha azul,
verão um exemplo de um guia de leitura;
e não apenas um exemplo qualquer,
é o guia de leitura para a
leitura da quinta-feira.
E vocês verão que ele faz 3 coisas.
A 1ª coisa que ele faz é oferecer
um contexto sobre o autor
e o texto que vamos ler.
A 2ª coisa que ele faz é
destacar os termos e conceitos
que eu espero que vocês
absorvam do material.
As noções e os termos que
permitirão a vocês
expressarem os pensamentos;
e o vocabulário
que permitirá a vocês
conversarem uns com os outros.
E a última coisa que o guia fornece
é um conjunto de perguntas
para focar a atenção
durante a leitura.
Não há nenhuma exigência de
responder a essas perguntas.
Vocês podem usá-las para
fazerem anotações;
podem usá-las numa
conversa com os colegas.
Vocês terão essa orientação em cada
uma das leituras obrigatórias
e, em cada uma das leituras
recomendadas e opcionais,
informações sobre o autor.
A 2ª coisa importante sobre este curso
é a aula expositiva e as seções.
Eu adoro ver todos esses rostos
e gostaria de vê-los
durante todo o semestre.
Eu me comprometo a apresentar pelo
menos um slide divertido
por aula.
Portanto, eu realmente espero
que vocês venham,
porque ao publicar os
slides no site vocês
não poderão ver a
animação do bom pastor.
Eu tentarei que as aulas
sejam muito envolventes,
e o mesmo com as seções.
Vamos nos esforçar para que seja
assim, que vocês possam se
envolver de verdade com o
material e uns com os outros.
Eu me dei conta que um dos
horários disponíveis
de seção é na quinta-feira das
10h30 às 11h20, o que, claro,
choca com a aula expositiva.
Logicamente, é um erro de digitação
e vamos proporcionar horários
extras para compensar isso.
O registro na seção ocorre
da forma habitual.
Além disso, haverá 10 breves
exercícios dirigidos.
Eu já comentei um pouco sobre eles
e há informações no
conteúdo programático
sobre os valores dos pontos na
definição das suas notas finais.
Há 2 ensaios curtos.
Serão 3 no total e você pode
escolher os 2 da sua preferência.
E, por último, haverá uma prova
final, onde, de acordo com a teoria
do curso, eu tenho de entregar com
antecedência cada uma das
perguntas que podem aparecer na prova.
Eu vou incentivá-los a
absorver o material
de forma orientada e estruturada.
E a prova será composta por um
subconjunto adequado dessas
questões, que vocês tiveram
tempo de se prepararem.
Portanto, esse é um resumo do que eu
pretendo fazer neste semestre.
1º, o tipo de curso;
em 2º lugar, 3 exemplos de
temas que abordaremos;
em 3º lugar, algumas das coisas
que distinguem o curso
e alguns dos seus requisitos.
Então, alguma pergunta? Sim?
Estudante: [inaudível]
Profª. Tamar Gendler:
Então a dúvida é
se os vídeos das aulas
serão publicados?
A resposta é: os vídeos das
aulas levam tempo para serem
editados e processados, portanto
eles serão publicados,
mas não durante o curso.
Após cada aula eu vou
publicar os slides,
mas como vocês viram,
eles não fornecem tanta
informação assim.
Sim?
Estudante: [inaudível]
Profª. Tamar Gendler: Não.
Tudo no curso é feito por
via eletrônica;
por isso, todas as tarefas
devem ser enviadas
no servidor Classes*v2.
E o prazo para o 1º exercício
escrito é a próxima terça-feira
às 10h, mas como ainda estamos no
período de inscrições,
esse exercício será aceito até
sexta, sem penalização.
Mas tudo relacionado às aulas,
em termos de envios e
retornos de exercícios,
será feito on-line no nosso site.
Sim?
Estudante: Quando começam as seções?
Profª. Tamar Gendler: Quando
começam as seções?
As seções começam na 3ª
semana do semestre.
Sim?
Estudante: [inaudível]
Profª. Tamar Gendler: Sim.
Se você reparar no exercício dirigido
da amostra que dei a vocês,
no verso da folha azul...
Ele diz que os exercícios
dirigidos vão de 1% a 7% cada um;
eu vou dizer qual é o valor do
exercício dirigido?
A resposta é sim. Portanto, se
você virar a folha azul,
você verá que o exercício dirigido da
próxima semana tem 2 partes.
Uma é pegar um clicker;
que vale 1 ponto.
A outra é me dizer se você
desligará a internet e por quê.
De forma resumida. Os exercícios
dirigidos sempre dirão:
aqui está a questão, aqui está o
valor do ponto para a questão.
Mais alguma coisa?
Nós estamos em cima da
hora, de verdade!
Portanto, todos expuseram as suas
perguntas de forma extraordinária
e estou ansiosa para vê-los
na próxima aula.